wieder ein dorf unter blau gelbe fahne
es gibt wenig bilder wenig details über
die gegenoffensive der ukraine im süden
aber die wenigen wecken auch im westen
hoffnung dass waffen wirken
[Musik]
die ukraine setzt westliche waffen
gerade unglaublich effektiv ein bei den
europäischen ländern den vereinigten
staaten und den anderen in der
kontaktgruppe sollte es also eine echte
bereitschaft geben mehr waffen zu
liefern
rammstein die fünfte die ukraine
kontaktgruppe trifft sich wieder auf der
us-militärbasis doch diesmal stößt jene
bereitschaft mehr zu liefern ein
praktische grenzen vor allem in europa
die waffenlager der meisten
mitgliedstaaten sind vielleicht nicht
erschöpft aber doch weitgehend
aufgebraucht weil wir den ukrainern
schon viele waffen gegeben haben
doch nicht alle lager sind leer panzer
vom typ leopard wären lieferbar sie
wären was die ukraine jetzt brauche sagt
der frühere nato strategie fabrice
partie
die augen richten sich jetzt wirklich
auf deutschland oder auf alle länder die
in deutschland leopard-panzer gekauft
haben die könnten sie abgeben aber
berlin muss die erlaubnis zum export
geben durch countries to export wenn
kein nato staat liefert bislang
kampfpanzer westlicher bauart diesen
wunsch der ukraine schlug berlin zuletzt
am sonntag aus ramstein könnte solche
linien verschieben in jedem fall würden
die usa von europa mehr engagement
fordern
amerika wird betonen dass die usa nicht
allein die militärhilfe für die ukraine
auffrischen werden botschaft wird sein
auch europa muss seinen teil übernehmen
beide zusammen könnten aus ramstein mehr
machen
40 mitglieder als garantie mächte für
die ukraine ein gedankenspiel für einen
frieden irgendwann
rammstein als dauereinrichtung wäre ein
signal vor allem an russland dass diese
staaten immer alles tun werden damit
sich die ukraine verteidigen kann
derweil feiert die ukraine ihre piloten
und träumt davon dass sie einmal
umsteigen in die kampfjets des westens
und
im café ist mir jetzt unsere reporterin
katrin eigendorf zugeschaltet gut morgen
kathrin was erhofft man sich in kiew von
dem treffen der ukraine kontaktgruppe
heute in ramstein
ja die ukrainische regierung erhofft
sich natürlich das was die seit beginn
des krieges fordert fordert weitere
unterstützung in form von waffen aber
nicht nur in form von modernen waffen es
wurde ja gerade schon im beitrag erwähnt
dass vor allem schützenpanzer hier
dringend gebraucht werden es sind auch
aufklärungsmöglichkeiten um russische
artillerie zum beispiel zu orten die den
ukrainern sehr wichtig sind
verstärkungen in artillerie also
möglichkeit auch über weite entfernungen
russland anzugreifen russische
stellungen anzugreifen ein wichtiger
punkt in der ganzen debatte ist für die
ukraine aber auch ausbildung ihrer
soldaten die ukraine hat ja gegenüber
russland den großen vorteil dass sie
über sehr sehr viele engagierte junge
männer verfügte hier auch freiwillig an
die front gehen aber die verfügung nicht
alle über eine wirklich professionelle
ausbildung und die wirklich fit zu
machen
ja für diesen krieg das ist den
ukrainern auch ein großes anliegen du
fährst heute nahe an die front nach
kharkiv im osten des landes dort aber
auch im süden soll die ukrainische armee
mehrere ortschaften zurückerobert haben
was kannst du uns dazu sagen
ja das ist ein sehr differenziertes bild
was ich hier gibt es ist natürlich so
dass die ukraine jetzt an diesen beiden
fronten also einmal an der front im
osten also im nördlichen don bass und
auch im süden in rason was ja russisch
besetzt ist doch deutliche erfolge
erzielt hat ist es ihnen wirklich
gelungen vor allem im süden russischen
nachschub abzuschneiden das heißt
russland kommt jetzt wirklich unter
druck und ist nicht mehr in der lage in
der nötigen menge sowohl soldaten aber
auch munition nachzuschieben an diese
front und es ist den ukrainischen
militärs auch gelungen im donbass
deutlich die armee zurückzudrängen das
setzt russland unter druck aber man muss
sich hier keine illusionen machen dieser
krieg ist längst nicht in einer
entscheidenden phase für die ukraine zum
beispiel die stadt raacke wird weiter
schwer beschossen
da hat sich ja mal eine zeit lang etwas
ruhe eingestellt nachdem es den
ukrainern gelungen ist die russische
armee zurückzudrängen aber inzwischen
die zweitgrößte stadt des landes ist
wieder deutlich unter beschuss und in
ständigem alarm was sicherlich in
ramstein ein thema sein wird und glaube
ich auch aus sicht der internationalen
partner zu diskutieren es ist die frage
wohin will die ukraine eigentlich in
diesem krieg also wir haben es ja auf
der einen seite mit einer verteidigungs
form hier zu tun vor allem im don was
aber die ukraine macht jetzt immer
weiter deutlich sie wollen auch gebiete
und dabei auch die krim zurückerobern
also sie haben ja zum ersten mal auch
eingestanden dass sie auf der krim
militärisch aktiv sind da ist natürlich
die frage gehen die internationalen
partner damit und was ist eigentlich
letztendlich das kriegsziel
interessante informationen aus der
ukraine live aus kiew war dass katrin
eigendorf vielen dank